la saison précédente dans le bureau des
légendes je sais pas si vous connaissez
mal outre une flambée qui vient de finir
sa mission en syrie colonel comment vous
appeliez là-bas pour lefebvre et donc
vous avez été amené à rompre certaines
relations ça à travers tuant par madame
nadia mansour
toi viens tu me fais pas le salon du
dessin c'est quoi sa forme d'un geste 1
ça nous met tous en danger parce qu'on
est au bout de sa vraie vie oui ma fille
l'a vite et à manger
et se passe quelque chose quand les
islamistes détiennent un agent comme
cyclone il négocie très cher
en un cyclone
vous allez partir à téhéran pour repérer
des agr nucléaire iranien votre
formation de sismologues vous permettra
d'en approcher pas mal vous allez vous
faire engager par cet homme
résa mortazavi ont proposé d'intégrer
votre équipe de partir mais oui tu vas y
arriver
c'est pour ça qu'on t'a choisi au
démantèlement de l'arsenal nucléaire
iranien et à la jeunesse
pourquoi tu as à paris comment ça pour
que je suis à paris
tim espionne la tg se voudrait connaître
le contenu des discussions vous avez ici
jamais je ne trahirai mon pays si tu
parles d'un danger nos djoman shirt pro
b
elle peut le faire oui que notre cheikh
est le porte parole
vous venez de revivre la saison 1
découvrez le bureau des légendes
nouvelle saison lundi 9 mai sur canal+